Film Courage: I know you’re a fan of Joseph
Campbell (The Hero’s Journey).
Adam Skelter, Author/Story Artist/Screenwriter:
Yes.
Film Courage: And most people are.
There’s not really any criticism of him…is
there?
Adam: Well, I’ve learned so much from Joseph
Campbell.
I discovered him pretty young.
I was 16 or 17 when I started reading him
and I was amazed by it and of course the thing
that was nice about it was that he was the
foray into [Carl] Jung and the theory of archetypes
and things like that.
While Campbell is dense, it’s a totally
different thing to delve into, Jung and [Sigmund]
Freud and all those things.
And part of the issue is…and I know the
hero and the hero’s journey and people regard
the hero one of the central archetypes of
the character.
But I think Joseph Campbell illuminated certain
insights into story that were incredibly helpful
but I don’t think it’s enough of a complete
theory and I plan on doing a video [On Adam’s
Youtube channel] later just to get more specific.
But just to give a teaser ultimately when
we look at a hero, hero is a very specific
kind of character.
That’s why I tend to refer to things as
a protagonist versus a hero.
A hero is someone that exhibits certain virtues
and values that are considered ideal and usually
the story is about them testing their medal.
But the story can be so much more than just
kind of a vulgar propaganda on exhibiting
ideal virtues.
And that’s why I think the hero’s journey
is brilliant and fantastic.
One thing that I liked about Joseph Campbell
is that he was exploring the universality
of story structure but I don’t think it’s
enough of a complete paradigm because when
we look at why we tell stories, it doesn’t
quite account for the initiation of the tribe
or into the tribe and that’s what I think
is very fascinating to me is my next video
is about tribalism actually.
I’m in the process of talking about tribalism.
I set up the relationship between religion
and story in one video and I’m going to
tie into tribalism.
And I’m defining tribalism in a very specific
way.
I’m going to go into the biological imperatives
that form tribalism (in this little teaser).
There are different groups of people who define
themselves according to what their objectives
are.
So for example a community is a group of people
with a common interest.
A movement is a group of people with a common
cause.
A tribe is a group of people with a common
enemy.
They have very, very different ways of functioning.
If you have an enemy that usually creates
a…loyalty becomes very important, it’s
a virtue within the tribe.
Within a community of broad, open interests
you don’t necessarily need loyalty in order
to function.
You can just have voluntary interactions.
With tribalism because it defines itself by
its enemy and it presents it as a threat and
therefore hierarchy becomes very important.
A lot of stories throughout most of the history
of humanity were designed to help create those
hierarchies.
So because most tribes were surviving in the
context of a lot of constant threat (perpetual
threat) which means they had to live in very
rigid communities or rigid groups of people.
So the narratives in the stories they would
tell were always about hero structure.
They were designed to help people incorporate
these values and these virtues as vital to
survival.
So because of that, this hero’s journey
was ultimately a kind of propaganda because
it was designed to drive people’s behavior
and value system to be subject and loyal to
the tribe.
That’s why I think stories that are more
engaged and more engaged in moral ambiguity
have much more interesting things to tell
because they are not just interested in exposing
and propagating specific narrow values that
emphasize loyalty but instead will actually
explore the nature of the human condition.
And that’s what I think is a much more interesting
thing.
If we can understand the way that story is
a kind of exploration of values rather than
just a propagation of values, then I think
we actually have more meaningful discourse
in understanding story and humanity.